And then it begins to decrease. So at some maximum point right here we have figured out where our total profit is reaching its maximum.
Hey everyone! We are going to take a quick look at total revenue total cost and profit even though it's not listed there for the competitive firm. Let's go ahead and dive into it.
Here I have a nice table and a pretty picture. That's really nice because now I don't have to draw it. You can see that this competitive firm is facing a price of $10. It's quantity goes from 0 to 8. We have total revenue, which is just price times quantity, going from $0 all the way to $80 and then we have our total cost. Now the total cost I didn't show you how I calculate that but if you go back to chapter 13 you will notice that this thing is increasing at this decreasing rate and then increasing at that increasing rate which holds with diminishing marginal returns. All right then we also have our profit which is total revenue minus total cost and that gives us some negative profit or economic loss to begin with. And then we have some positive profit here. And then because our costs outgrow our revenue we end up with more negative profit or economic loss. Look at these two curves that we have before us.
So the blue line is going to represent my total revenue and you'll notice that it is a straight line, so this blue line is again is a straight line because we do not have our price changing. Price stays the same, so revenue is going to incrementally grow by how much output it is multiplied by. And then we also have this green line being the total cost curve. And the area that is of interest is this area that's being shaded in right now. That is the area that represents positive economic profit--what we want to see for this firm. We do have two areas where these two curves intersect. This is where we're going to have no economic profits. It's going to actually be zero at that case. And then we have these outlying areas right here.
These are going to be where we experienced an economic loss. That is definitely where this competitive firm does not want to operate. So what we are really concerned with is figuring out where this firm is going to maximize its profit. We can already see profit at its highest of $8 with producing three and four units of output, so that's going to be somewhere around--this axis isn't quite
good there. But it's somewhere around this area. Because that represents the greatest difference between the total revenue curve and the total cost curve. So what we can look at and you can see this, and this looks really good, but let's have a look at the total profit curve. So you now notice that this profit curve will increase--we're getting out of the red going into the black--and then it begins to decrease. So at some maximum point right here we have figured out where our total profit is reaching its maximum.
And that happened to be at three and four units of output. But notice what is going on here. I introduced two new variables marginal revenue and marginal cost. Remember marginal revenue is going to be the change in total revenue over the change in quantity. And since quantity only increases by one it's real it's going to be a change in revenue for our case. So our marginal revenue never changes it always stays at 10. Here you can go back look. We go from 0 to $10. $10 to $20. $20 to $30. That is always a change of 10.
So we're going to have again our marginal revenue really just look like  our total revenue curve. It's going to be some flat line. And then our marginal cost is also our change in total cost so change in total cost over change in quantity. We do the same thing that we did with our marginal revenue. And these are the numbers that we end up with. Notice where the $10 equals $10 at 4 units of output. This is where my marginal revenue equals marginal cost. This is the Golden Rule of profit maximization. This is where firms want to operate. This is the amount of output that they want to produce in order to maximize their profit.
That happens to be at 4 units of output. That gives us the greatest distance between those two curves that is positive.
And if we were to look at
a straight line here and a straight line there, we would see that my slope of my marginal revenue curve is equal to the slope of my marginal cost curve. So here we have we figured out where we want to operate. You figured out the profit maximization point--total profit. This is what we want and that is all we have. So hope you've enjoyed it and I'll catch you in our next video.